foreign
so we're going to start this AMA I have
an overactive conscience and was raised
to over apologize you have an overactive
conscious conscience I do I tend to
apologize you have like three open beers
under the counter right now nope no I
don't mother no I don't
know gangster what's up this is the Dr
John delone show and I'm so glad that
you're with us on the greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting
podcast ever ever recorded just gonna
keep saying it keep saying it keep
saying it so glad that you're with us
um it is one day two days before New
Year's two days two days
before my favorite moment of the year
and if you've been riding with us for a
couple years you know New Year's is my
favorite time because all of us just
collectively take a mulligan we're all
like you can literally say anything like
ah man I really got into heroin bad but
my New Year's resolution is and
everyone's like cool that sounds great
it's like man I uh I just started
burning down people's homes but like my
New Year's resolution no more arson
everyone's like awesome that sounds
great you can say whatever you want you
just get a mulligan you get a control
delete on whatever just happened and I I
know you can you can change your life
whenever on any random Tuesday right
um and I I've I've had to do that this
year but I just love New Year's as a
time that we all collectively exhale and
we're like let's do that one again let's
let's do that one again so I'm glad that
you're with us
um as we do every year on
um
the New Year's show or right before New
Year's right after New Year's is uh we
do an AMA ask me anything questions that
people have written in Jenna and uh
Kelly still out
um taking care of her family her mom
passed away and so our thoughts and
prayers are still with her
um and Jenna is here to
run things hey before we get going
listen the show that you actually
listened to or watch
it's very different than the show we
record because the show we record is
full of me stumbling and messing things
up and saying things incorrectly and
saying things that would get me fired
all that in the great Sarah just had a
birthday so happy birthday Sarah 21 is a
big one you can drink beers now so it's
gonna be weird but happy birthday and
congratulations on making this far it's
so awesome uh all right so Jenna the
Force is with you
yes thank you let's do this and with you
too all right so we're going to start
this AMA first question are you ready
um let's do it this is the one that
everybody wants to know what is your
current morning routine okay
um
so backing up three years it was intense
it was like 14 different things or 50
different things and I crammed it all in
an hour and a half in the morning it was
very regimented and then last year
um my life exploded on this show not in
a bad way but like I just started
traveling all over the country and was
writing and things just went bananas and
really I got off in a pretty major way
and so
um I Revisited the importance of the
morning so there's tons of research out
there tons of data taking ownership of
your morning
is critical
having an intentional plan for your
morning whatever that looks like for you
and there's some debate on what's good
and what's not good and when you should
drink caffeine and when you shouldn't
drink coffee for most of us there's uh
so there's a there's a group of
optimizers people who are living their
best life they're making a bajillion
dollars their things are under control
and they want to take that to the next
level awesome
I have found millions and millions and
millions and millions of people just
like me
whose life is just uh frog's hair away
from being a mess and so how can we
begin to get a hold of that
intentionality and let's practice that
for a year and then after that let's
begin working on optimization and making
things the schedules Tighter and things
a little more better and should I do
work out first and then eat or should I
eat and then should I fast but
let's get the basics the blocking and
tackling down so all to say is I had to
revisit mine about halfway through this
year what's my morning how am I going to
re be intentional about my mornings and
so I was like this morning
um got up at a little around right
around five a little bit after five and
I checked my HRV which is a thing I do
all the time
um and with my whoop strap I check my
HRV and then I went downstairs and had a
giant glass of water and then I went
down and I either read I'm in the middle
of writing another book or I write for
um about 20 30 minutes in front of a big
light uh it's it's one of those Winter
Lights the seasonal affective disorder
lights
um but you can get it anywhere but
getting light
um and it's been really rainy and gray
here in Nashville but morning sunlight
huberman's done a great job talking
about that so that's been a that's
always been a part of my practice but
it's become even more intentional
um so I sit in front of the light and
let my body your mind fully wake up I do
drink coffee right out of the gate I
drink coffee and then do a really tough
tough workout in the morning and so
there is some research that says waiting
an hour and an hour and a half maybe two
hours before you consume caffeine
for me hopping right into a hard workout
is important so I then go from there to
my workout so it's about 5 30 5 45 now
and I've got my workouts on most days
down to about 30 to 45 minutes
um and uh
foreign it just depends on what season
I'm in I've been running the maps
program from the Mind pump guys right
now I've I've created my own workout
program that is really hard and it's
really but it's not very long and so
um then I get to working out and then I
try to go upstairs and be totally
present with my kids by the way no
phones the to the best of the best I can
I do fall off that wagon but no phones
usually uh I have to turn my phone off
and put it in my bag and let that just
be off
um my whoop strap has a alarm on it that
can wake me up in the morning and I rely
on that
um
and then I go hang out with my kids and
do the morning stuff and take all my
foreign vitamins and do all that you
like that product plug that was pretty
good and then on Tuesdays I take uh Hank
and I my 12 year old and I go to
breakfast this morning Josephine and I
went to breakfast at Waffle House not a
healthy restaurant at all not even
pretending to be but still awesome and
um
my daughter and I had a blast this
morning I found out somebody has a
girlfriend and somebody's got a
boyfriend and they're only in
kindergarten and it's just a scandal it
was awesome
um I spent time with him I do try to
spend three or four minutes attention
with my wife in the morning just to
check in what's the picture of today
look like and
um then I head off into work and so
globally speaking I did take my cold
showers in the morning so I get some
light exposure some significant light
exposure some really hard exercise I do
eat breakfast I've been eating breakfast
for the last year or so which if you're
new to the show you're like uh is that
weird
um I was did intermittent fasting for
years and so I just never had breakfast
um I have to eat breakfast again for a
whole host of reasons so this nobody
cares about
um and cold exposure and really close
connective time and then I'm off to work
man that whole thing takes about an hour
hour and a half
um sometimes a little bit more sometimes
a little bit less
um and then occasionally I gotta write
or something so it blows up my whole
morning great I owe my body a workout I
owe my body some movement and we'll just
go get that done so that's my current
morning routine is that like yours
yes exactly exactly you just read my
exact it's like you read my diary or
something I did actually yeah your
husband sent the diary we're gonna read
that in the next section oh great love
it yeah we can't wait um yeah no I don't
really have one I probably should get a
credit Mooring Jenna I just like roll
out of bed and then I get ready and I go
out the door
um next question
um how to get a cigarette
I shake off the morning get a Coors
Light and then head to the office pretty
much all right next question how do I
talk to my father about his health and
do I get a vote
directly in no
um that's a loaded question because I
don't know how old her dad is I don't
know how old this person is
um I'll tell you about a conversation I
had with my Dad recently like how are
you how are things going how's your hey
I just got some numbers back from a
blood some blood work idea how does that
compare to your blood work
um hey I tried this this particular
invention over this thing so
um I have a pretty open dialogue with my
dad about that kind of stuff
um I did I got a colonoscopy a few
months I think I talked about this I got
it and I called my mom and said hey I
told you I'm going to get a philosophy I
don't know why I didn't call her just
for that we're talking about something
else I don't I don't call my mom like
Mom guess what's happening I didn't I
didn't do that but she said oh that's
probably a great thing and she rattled
off all these people in my family
history with
if had called cancer and I was like Mom
I need to know that and she's like I
know so uh my dad and I talk about it
here's
um where I don't get a vote
I don't get a vote on what he eats I
don't get a vote on his weight I don't
get a vote on whether he works out or he
doesn't work out
um if he becomes incapacitated then
we've had discussions on medical power
of attorneys and things like that but
when it comes to the choices my grown
father chooses about his health no I
don't get a vote I can't make him do
something
um until again he becomes capacitated
incapacitated and I become his legal
guardian
but I do believe in expressing love and
care to our parents hey I'm worried
about you
um you haven't seen your seemed like
yourself lately man you've lost a ton of
weight you look amazing or hey you don't
look as healthy as last time I saw you
you're doing okay
if you don't have that kind of
relationship with your parents and you
just launch out of the gate with wow you
put some pounds on that's a recipe for
disaster don't do that
but I do think spending some adult time
with your parents if you can and in your
in proximity sometimes my Mom and I went
for a long walk when I was back in town
sometimes my dad and I will go to
breakfast together
um but there's something about saying
hey check in how are you how you feeling
how are things going
um anything change with the will
anything change with like so that's just
a regular part of our conversation but I
also have to hold Loosely I don't get a
vote I don't get to decide how he's
going to live his life
that's good
um next question
man this one really hits home I have an
overactive conscience and was raised to
over apologize how do I get out of this
oof
you have an overactive conscious
conscience
you me why is that surprising I don't
know I do I tend to apologize you have
like three open beers under the counter
right now oh good cooler no no I don't
mother no I don't
um so uh over apologizing let me ask you
what does over apologizing get you
I think I just feel like I don't want
somebody to think that I purposefully
did something or like if I messed up I
feel like I have to apologize because
that's not my attention like I don't
want them to think that of me okay tell
me tell me if I'm wrong
The Pursuit of Happiness which I think
is is insane
turns into the avoidance of discomfort
and I often so we've created a culture
for ourselves which I'm fully a member
of where we don't know how to be
uncomfortable like the woman who called
said yesterday on the show she's like I
quit smoking weed and now I just feel
like I'm standing there wondering what
to do with my hands yep because I
haven't felt awkward before because I
just smoked and covered it up or I ain't
covered up or I spent and covered it up
or I went and hooked up some of this
cover up whatever our addiction of the
day is
and so
um apologizing over apology I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry that is a way I can
offload any discomfort
so it's less about them and it's more
about protecting me
and so if somebody wants to
stop being an over apologizer
then you have to be willing to sit in
relational discomfort that isn't of your
volition
meaning when you over apologize you are
trying to take ownership of how somebody
else feels and fix it for them you can't
they are adults and they get to choose
that does that make sense yes that
definitely makes sense so why do you do
that
I'm just kidding this is the worst
question no no counselor should ever ask
why why'd you do that
um that's not a good question to ask
um so I think it would be you have to be
willing to be uncomfortable
and to say I can only control me I
didn't try to hurt that person this
person is choosing to be hurt by what I
said I'm sorry that they're
uncomfortable and if they want to need
to explain more if they want me to to
dig into I'm all for that but I can't
just walk around like oh I'm so sorry
I'm so I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry and
by the way not only are we covering up
for our own discomfort we're trying to
take away discomfort for somebody else
and if so like I don't have that kind of
power I'd like to think I do like my
kids feel uncomfortable oh I'm so sorry
son my son's like Dad I I I didn't do
this it's on me I'm like I know I'm just
so sorry I can't take away that hurt I
it'd be better if I just went and sat
with him and hugged him and said this is
the worst man you know what I mean it's
a different thing yeah that's that's
really good stop apologizing I know I
need to stop apologizing I feel like I
just sometimes I'm like I just need to
be like in con I'm like to be in control
and I feel like when I'm not in control
of like how somebody perceives I don't
know I need to just let it go
yes awesome okay next question what
exactly are intrusive thoughts
intrusive thoughts are lightning bolts
they are you're walking down the road
and you see somebody in a particular
kind of jeans and you instantly go back
to that girlfriend you had or that
boyfriend you had and then that thing
they said to you like it is Boom or if
heaven forbid you've lost a child or a
loved one
um it's you're just doing something and
you look in that picture of them in the
funeral home pops into your mind or that
feeling you get
um when something happened to you years
ago and it just it just it just
re-emerges
um so that is an intrusive thought they
just come
most people think that at the end of the
intrusive thought
the cascading sense of worry and shame
and now my body's trying to protect me
all that I just have to deal with that
and that's not true
the moment an intrusive thought happens
boom I'm gonna take ownership of it so
I'm gonna remember that picture I am
choosing I'm not going to think about my
kid at the funeral home I'm gonna think
about my kid laughing so hard cotton
candy and milk came out her nose at the
same time I'm gonna in not intentionally
uh by the time you got dumped and when
so-and-so said this I'm not going to
meditate on that I'm going to meditate
on the person I'm with right now and how
much we laugh together and how much fun
we have and what will happen over time
is your brains will stop it will begin
to change the automatic dial from these
moments of remember watch out to
look how beautiful look how beautiful
look how beautiful
um and quite honestly intrusive thoughts
are just they just are what they are I I
just don't lose a lot of sleep with them
anymore I used to let them run my life
and they just don't get a vote anymore
do you have them
yes I think I do yeah yeah
I think I have intrusive thoughts of
like more so of I don't trust myself
um I have a huge fear of heights and so
I find myself like if I'm up high
somewhere I'm like I don't trust myself
to like I don't want to hurt myself but
I don't trust myself to not throw me off
this ledge so I just avoid it
I know that seems weird but I should go
see somebody it's like
like I'm just like escalators I hate
escalators because I know there's
nothing on the sides of them and I get
on the escalator I'm like but what if I
just like something in me just is like
flips over and I fall out and I just
and so that's that's a great moment the
moment you think what if
if you were able to go nope
my body's trying to protect me thank you
I'm good escalators is going to the top
and we're able to cut that sucker off
right there and smile about it not go
but go oh look my brain started to carry
me again I'm Square I'm good not a lot
of people fall off escalators it happens
they're on Instagram but very rarely
right
um over time your brain will stop trying
to get your attention on escalators
because it knows like uh Jen is fine she
doesn't fall off escalators only
they do right it's awesome very cool all
right hey let's take a break we'll be
right back on the Dr John Dylan show
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement nmls ID
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org Equal
Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
[Music]
another installment
to me anything new year's Edition
on
John show
I think we should move to John's show
people that get confused I think it's
about toilets I was literally just
thinking I was like they might be like
we discussed different kinds of commodes
and toilets it's a really riveting show
so exciting all right on to the next AMA
on to the next question my family makes
fun of me for seeing a therapist what
should I do quit telling your family
that you see a therapist
foreign
we have this culture of over sharing
like we're obsessed with over sharing
um and I did I realized in the last
segment I just I told my mom that I went
got a colonoscopy
um our family talks about that kind of
stuff but a lot of I don't tell my
parents
um every time my wife and I have a fight
I don't tell them what I'm seeing a
marriage counselor I didn't tell my
parents I was seeing a regular counselor
or the psychologist or the therapist
that's often I don't I have I I have a
coach that I talk to semi-regularly I
don't tell my parents about that I don't
tell them it's not their business it's
not their they don't need to know that
stuff
um and if people are gonna make fun of
you for getting the help and care that
you need they are by their behavior
remember behavior is a language they are
telling you
um we don't care about you that much we
are opting out of parts of your life
cool you are free to go you're free to
go
um so really with anything if I feel
strongly about something
um let me I'm trying to think
here's a good example hunting uh I think
I've talked about on the show not like
that's a that's a big part of my life my
family
um we probably three or four nights a
week eat wild game throughout the year
and so in the fall during hunting season
that's a big season for us I hate
killing I don't like it
um I do like provision and I do it's a
spiritual thing for me and I've brought
my son along with me and I've also got
some friends that I do this with
um and so it's a part of our life I also
have friends that are hardcore vegans
that are very anti-guns that are great
that's I'm I love them our kids play
together they spend the night at my
house when they're in town that's
awesome
I intentionally am hospitable and I
don't talk about hunting with them
because I don't wanna I don't have a
fight I don't have a discussion on
people uncomfortable I'm just not that
guy
um and I know some of you are like oh
they gotta you gotta be able to no you
don't stop
stop be hospitable so that's just like I
understand if you're gonna make fun of
me you're gonna talk about I just won't
break it up with you and that's cool and
I'll keep that part of my life to myself
and that's all good every single person
I interact with every person I love and
care about doesn't have access to every
part of me
that's good all right next question I
just had a baby and I'm concerned about
the rise of RSV my family gets mad when
I won't let them hold her what can I do
to keep her safe your family doesn't get
a vote they don't get a vote and
first time baby
[Music]
um
was I'll just say anxiety even though
it's that's not clinically accurate just
the anxiousness you get about
cleanliness am I doing this right is
this the right diaper or is
microplastic's gonna get in my baby and
it's the pollution gonna do this and
what about it
that's completely normal and so what I
know about me is when I get
um worked up about something I get
really emotional about something when I
get emotional about something
neurologically I don't make good choices
and so one of my life's goals
is to have a person
just today just today I called a friend
who's a banker who I love and I trust
and I said I'm having a challenge with a
financial decision I'm going to make
and you are going to get the final
decision
and he said go for it because we've I he
knows this is how I operate and I trust
him implicitly
and he knows me for 30 years now he also
knows
um the financial markets and he knows a
keynote he's one of the he's a part of
my will like in terms of being executive
so he knows how much money I make and
how much money I have I'm completely
open with him and I said hey
um
what should I do about this and he said
I would do this that's what I'm gonna do
because I've outsourced that decision so
I tell you that to tell you one of my
goals is to have a guy have a have a
woman who's brilliant at a thing have a
man who's a brilliant at a thing
um and so
when you find yourself getting anxious
about your new baby have one or two
friends someone may be a nurse
practitioner somebody may be a neonatal
nurse not everybody's got access to that
so have a doctor that you can call hey
I'm really worried about this is it okay
to let my family hold my baby because
I'm going to Outsource those decisions
that make me extra extra emotional I did
that with covid and with all the
vaccines and all the drama I knew I've
got real strong opinions and I might be
completely wrong so I'm gonna call
people that I trust in other areas of my
life and help and get there in more
informed position than mine right and I
do that with a lot of things and it just
makes a lot more peace in my life
because here's what I've come to find
out the wisest smartest smartest wisest
and most peaceful people I know say the
words I don't know but I can find out
more than anybody else I know
it's those who really struggle with
self-esteem those who really struggle
with their place in the world those who
really are trying to prove to everybody
how smart they are that always have an
opinion on everything and I I know
that's ironic because I got a show where
I'm always telling my opinion but if you
know me just hanging out I it I'll be I
don't know I don't know what do you
think I I don't know
um and I I just think that's the sign of
true wisdom so if you're struggling with
the rise of RSV and a new baby have a
medical professional who knows what
they're talking about that you trust and
ask them
then if they say yeah it's so okay for
your family to hold your baby
um then when you hand your baby over
feel that anxiousness ah my body's
trying to protect me and my baby and
then exhale
and baby's gonna be all right probably
and also know this having a baby is
scary because something could happen
you gotta always hold that that could
happen it could and trying to be a
parent that prevents everything ever
from ever happening to your kid is a
um
that's a that's a that's a miserable
life for you and that child and so we're
not gonna be We're Not Gonna not have
caution We're Not Gonna Be moronic but
also we're going to release we're going
to open our hands right call the doctor
call your friend and let's get some good
information and if it's not safe to let
your parents or family hold the baby
we're gonna say no thank you
or um baby's not We're not gonna let the
baby be held this time
cool and if they are like oh my God then
they don't get to see the baby tada
um
and I'm I'm gonna feel guilty about it
I'm gonna feel sad about it but I'm
gonna move on with my life
um what is the difference between
healing versus management and
we'd be fully healed
man so that could be a number of things
I'm just gonna assume it's like about
trauma or anxiety maybe what do you
think
yes
um I would say it just says like mental
health issues like in general like
anxiety probably so management is let's
use anxiety management is I feel anxious
so I've got five or ten breathing
exercises and some apps on my phone and
I've got some CBD Gummies at all time
and I have uh I don't ever watch TV
because the news mix and I avoid all
that and I never look at my uh tax
returns or my uh
401K returns and I completely avoid this
part of the office because there's that
one person over there and she's the
worst or he's the worst so
I can manage my anxiety through
some hacks some techniques and some
avoidance I can manage that I can do
that and there is times and seasons and
that's really important for instance I
got a big speech to give in front of 5
000 people I may get anxious about it
I'm going to manage the anxiousness but
the anxiousness is right it's good
because I'm about to go in front of 5
000 people this could go horribly awry
right so there's gonna be some things
I'm going to manage it I'm not gonna
have as much caffeine I'm gonna do
several things that that I've
that work for me
healing is
creating and you hear me say this all
the time creating a non-anxious life
healing looks like I just go to bed on
time and I don't overdo it on the
caffeine and the stimulants and I only
have sugar when I'm celebrating
something I just don't make that a
regular part of my life and I make sure
I check in with my wife on a regular
basis and my kids on a regular basis I'm
giving my nervous system a chance to
settle in
so that it is ready for when an actual
threat shows up it's not running hot all
the time and just going from hot to
hotter it's going from a low level
hum to oh this is a pretty serious thing
you should probably check into that's
healing
and so I was in Texas a couple days ago
um for holidays and hunting trips just
hanging out with some guys who also knew
me if you read on your past change your
future there are some of the guys I
called to come look at my house but I
thought the whole house was falling down
right during 0809 2010 during the
financial crisis I was an anxious Basket
Case mess
and I tried to manage my anxiety through
the right workout program and the right
diet and the right Bible study program
and the right this and the right degree
and the right job title I try to manage
it
and then over the last 10 years I've
really worked hard to heal from my
challenges and I had to go back to the
well and my relationships on the stories
I was telling myself on my health on a
number of issues
um I had to stop keeping secrets I had
to tell the truth about some hard things
I just had to shift and change and
create I had to pay off my debts I had
to stop owing people money I had to stop
coming up with schemes about this I had
to just settle in it's gonna be my job
it's gonna be my job I'm gonna quit
applying for job I said create a
non-anxious life I had to get rid of
clutter and crap everywhere in my house
and in my life
and now we stumble into 2022 and there's
inflation crisis and there's all kind of
Market Madness we're gonna have a
recession are we gonna have recession oh
my gosh and every day is the next new
drama
I literally have no anxiety about it
zero none and my buddies were act like
dude are you like on dope are you on
taking heroin like how are you this
chill I'm like no I mean I see the
numbers and I don't like it when I go to
the grocery store and I have to make
alternative routes because the gas
prices are so expensive and I can't
afford to fill up like that all the time
and I quit buying this and we decided to
do this instead and Christmas is going
to look different this year
but my body isn't taking off ahead of me
in an attempt to defend me and fight
Wars for me that haven't happened yet
and so yes I believe you can heal I
really really do I believe you can heal
from trauma so that you can think about
you can remember you can feel the sexual
abuse
um you can feel
not the actual sexual abuse but you can
feel your body take off on your heart
rate drop you can feel the getting fired
the divorce the dad when he hit you way
way way too hard
and your body doesn't try to protect you
in the present because it knows it's in
the past and it also is healed your
nervous system is adjusted to your new
Norm
and we're going to move forward so I
absolutely think management of uh
symptoms is really important especially
when you're on a path to Healing
um but yes I believe with all I wouldn't
be doing this job if it was just about
management I really believe with all my
heart and I've experienced it in myself
and countless other people
absolutely you can
heal and healing is uncomfortable it's
like after surgery man go into rehab
it's the worst like you have to do all
those exercises with your shoulders and
knees and everyone's watching it's the
worst
and healing's on the other side of that
right
yep that's really good
um how do you get a healthy amount of
sleep with a full-time job and two kids
at home dude uh
that's the worst it's the worst on top
of the worst on top of the worst my
sleep has fallen into a dark hole of
sadness it's a mess it's just not great
um my whoop strap the last few weeks I
just I wake up and it looks at me and
goes that wasn't sleeping like it just
just not happy with me
um so
the only word I can let me tell you a
couple things if you have two little
kids
you're just gonna have a season where
getting sleep is going to be a challenge
just remember it's a season the same as
in the winter time there's just gonna be
a time walking from your front door to
your car or going through doing your
exercises outside when it's
uncomfortable it's cold gotta wear a
jacket or I gotta wear tights underneath
my workout clothes like a goofball right
it's just it's just a season
so if you've got two little ones you got
a two-year-old and a one-year-old
getting nine hours of sleep a night is
is just about impossible I don't know a
scenario
I do know that I'm gonna work extra hard
on not overdoing it on my exercise
routine even though I am going to make
sure I exercise I'm gonna be extra
cautious about how much screen time I
get I'm gonna be almost pathological but
not quite on nutrition and what foods
I'm putting into my body I'm gonna be
super pathological about having other
people in my life
so if I look at sleep as a major major
lever
in a non-anxious life
and that one is going to be not able to
I can't pull it all the way because I
got two little kids or I've got a huge
work assignment due or we're moving in
this and my husband just got laid off
and my wife is this okay I know this so
I can toggle the other levers
um and that's just called intentionality
and it's also called boring and really
annoying and super frustrating
it's not fun it's not fun not knowing
what's going on in the world it's not
fun turning all your electronics off at
7 pm all of them because then you're
gonna sit there staring at your spouse
and your two-year-old and you're like
what do we do now
um it's not fun it's just not like let's
go for another walk let's go for another
another walk
but that's the path right and then if
you're like me I got two kids I got 12
year old and a six-year-old
almost entirely
my sleep issues I've been averaging
five to six and a half hours for the
last couple of months it's really not
good
um
it's a hundred percent on me
I wish I could blame somebody it's 100
on me going to bed getting off my stupid
phone not watching another show and then
another show and another show I started
reading fiction several years ago at
bedtime I don't read science in bed
anymore and then I got into some good
fiction recently and I'm reading two
hours before I go to sleep that's just I
stop I have to be a grown-up and say no
more right no more
um
that's hard because I love I love all
the other things but I know that I can't
be the dad I need to be the husband I
need to be the professional I need to be
I can't show up for you I can't show up
for myself if I don't have seven to nine
hours of good sleep and so 2023 that is
one of my main focuses I'm a guy who
will be on time and a guy who will get
sleep those are two of my major major
shifts going into 2023. so
uh sleep's the worst and you gotta you
got it all right we'll be right back and
we will wrap up the AMA when we come
back stay with us
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help betterhelp is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back for the third and
final section of the AMA let's do this
what you got let's kick it out
get on one
because some people can't hear it some
people don't want to hear it so people
never want to talk to you again ever
some people blame you for all of the
things in their lives and you calling
them saying hey I forgive you
um creates a whole hurricane blizzard
diarrhea storm like no no don't
forgiveness is you deciding I will no
longer carry the weights you have put in
my backpack I'm done carrying them you
don't have the power to make me angry
anymore you don't have the power to make
me sad or upset or cry anymore I am
taking away your power to do that
there is some really cathartic beautiful
relational moments when you can look at
somebody and say I forgive you
I'm setting this down and that can be
life-giving to people
um
often you know
often you know that um
this conversation is going to be
fruitful it's going to be productive but
other than that no you do not have to
tell somebody
to their face I forgive you for it to
count forgiveness is an internal
exercise I am no longer carrying your
crap
all right next question you disagree you
look like you disagree with that no I
don't disagree with that okay no I'm
just in the game oh you're in a Zone
sorry I gotta make sure I read these
questions right a lot of pressure I got
Kelly's shoes to fill now oh there's
like size fours
you're so small
how do I grow up and become an adult
when I lacked childhood discipline I
don't want to grow up because um listen
I don't care what happened uh what you
lacked as a kid
Tada you're an adult now and you get to
make adult choices
I would instead of being like well this
happened when I was I don't care
the real Choice the real question you
gotta ask yourself is what am I going to
do next
and if you didn't learn childhood
discipline right you didn't have
childhood discipline nobody made you
make the bed nobody made you turn things
in on time and now you keep getting
fired from your job because you are
show up uh
and you're non-hygienic or you show up
and you're not getting your work done
and you're like I didn't get it done on
time and like well you're fired because
I had to be done on time
you get to choose from this point
forward I'm going to begin to practice
discipline in a major major way
I'm gonna get with people who are
successful who are one step two steps
ten steps ahead of me in a particular
job in a particular field in a
particular they're married and I'm not
they've got kids and I don't whatever
they're it's super fit and I'm not and
I'm gonna ask them I'm gonna take them
to coffee take them to dinner and say
all right I need to pick your brain how
do we get from A to B
and there's no harm like I've done that
with Jocko I've done that with Sal and
the mind pump guys I've done that with
Dr Lane Norton I do that with Dave
Ramsey I do that regularly
hey help me with this I call Rachel Cruz
the other day I was like Hey help me
think through this because I'm thinking
it's it's all about getting wise counsel
from people I did that this like I said
I did this morning with my buddy Todd
there in Houston I mean they're in uh in
West Texas
I'm always seeking wise counsel from
people for things I don't know how to do
so I want you to start looking at this
lack of discipline as a set of skills
you don't have that you can learn just
like kicking a soccer ball just like
strumming a guitar just like learning
how to cook it's a set of skills that if
you want to you can learn
but this excuse like nobody made me make
my bed don't give a crap
get to work on time nobody ever made me
I don't care your boss is gonna or
you're not gonna eat it's up to you as
the adult to solve this problem
tada
does that mean I don't mean to be me I
kind of mean to be mean on that one no I
think you yeah just stop okay good
um why is being busy so praised in this
culture
hmm I don't know
I'll just think through it out loud
um say it one more time why is being
busy so praised in this culture
I think in this culture
we have defined
we have a number attached to the
question what are you worth
that's a math problem in the western
world
it's not a relational question it's not
a spiritual question it's a math problem
it's all the vacations you did it didn't
go on all of the the colleges you didn't
attend the clothes you didn't buy the
raises you did or didn't get whatever
what are you worth how much money do you
have
in accounts and in the bank and in your
cars like how much you got
and
stemming from what are you worth it is a
question like so what have you done to
get that worth
and underneath what have you done is how
hard have you worked to get that worth
now
it's cool and in Vogue these days to to
assume that everybody who's got wealth
or resources who've done or it's are
successful just inherited that or stole
it from people and that's simply not
true the data suggests that most most
most millionaires in this country
are first first gen man they are
figuring this thing out and they're
worked really really really hard or
they've been very very disciplined
um the stunning stat was the third
highest category of millionaires the
United States is teachers
they don't make a lot of money which
tells me they have made choices like oh
I've chosen a profession which means I'm
gonna have to choose a lifestyle that is
supported by that profession I'm going
to be a Corolla person because I'm
dedicated to being a teacher I'm not
ever going to be a Lexus person or a
giant Suburban person
I'm gonna drive a Corolla and probably a
used one of that and that's what I'm
gonna do because that's the life I want
to live and so I'm going to live within
my means I'm going to retire I mean I'm
going to save I'm going to create this
world right
underneath that is this idea that
[Music]
busy gets you more stuff
and more stuff gets you more worth
and so
I think we've just equated and there's
also an Antiquated that's going away
very very fast butts and seeds all right
be the first person and the last person
out
that's going away quickly too do a good
job do your job really really well and
if you can get done early knock your
lights out man or go pick up and help
your neighbor or someone in the office
but I think being busy has been equated
to production and production has been
equated to
uh accumulation of things and
accumulation of things have been equated
to worth and so all of that stems back
to be really busy all the time and by
the way busy is a good drug busy is a
great great drug it gives us something
to do
when we feel less than when we feel uh
idle when we feel out of step with our
relationships I'm just gonna go be busy
I'm gonna go dude
um and it helps us wallpaper over that a
little bit I know what do you think do
you have an opinion on that
um yes I feel yeah I feel like it goes
back to like it's our worth like if
we're more busy than the next person
we're worth more it's that we're more
valuable more valuable I'm more valuable
because I was able to do more or it's
kind of like a one-up kind of thing you
did this and this well I had to do this
this and this so it's like it yeah it
goes back to you're more valued the more
that you do I like that um last question
okay I just started going to therapy is
it always so draining and emotional
no you wrote that question in dang it
thank you thank you for putting that
question in Jenna
um no it is not uh depending on why you
went to therapy and what you and your
therapists are working through
um
it's I mean it's just like going to the
gym there's times you go to the gym and
it is miserable and or you want to lose
30 pounds that first I mean getting back
into the swing of things is hard it's
draining you just leave all beat up and
in short order you start leaving the gym
with tons more energy my workout this
morning was brutal and I left just
electrified and I feel so good man and
so uh there will be Seasons when you
leave the counselor counselor and you
cannot wait to go Take On The World
you've got some new tools you're able to
process some things you feel lighter so
you feel good
um but at the beginning when you're just
saying some things for the first time
when you are allowing your body to
finally feel some of those things for
the first time the shame the regret the
sadness the Heartbreak the fear the
anxiousness all those feelings
you do that for the first time it's
overwhelming that's why having a
therapist is so important because you've
got somebody that are with you
figuratively like holding your hand
right
um but no it will not be like that
forever stick it out I tell people
unless there's just a clear ethical
violation or a clear like this is a bad
Vibe I am finding myself lying to this
person because I can't be in their
presence
um stick it out three or four sessions
and you go stick it out three or four
sessions get through get through that
initial and get to the other side of it
um and that's where the piece is the
only way to heal is doing the hard hard
work is going right through the middle
of it that's it man so great great
question on that one all right hang on
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey thanks for
being with us during the AMA is kind of
a loose fitting uh jacket that feels
good man it's just kind of house hanging
out so thank you if you have questions
um we're gonna do more amas coming up we
just get a lot of off the like hey I
have a quick question about this or what
do you think about this
um that isn't always wrapped up in a
call so write your questions in go to
John deloney.com ask ask and Jenna will
get those and you can just put AMA um
question and you can ask that ama
question and uh thank you so much for
being with us and
be intentional about your New Year's
resolutions uh I'm I I'm so excited
about it we'll talk about my news
resolutions coming up in the next show
um as we wrap up today's today's uh Ama
it's the great Nathan the guy working
all of the uh screens back there you
would not know this
he's quiet he's very very talented the
most talented guys I've ever worked with
he is obsessed with Katy Perry
he's always wearing Katy Perry t-shirts
his Katy Perry tattoo is like a big old
I mean it's a whole thing it takes about
you know people always like hey you want
to see pictures of my kids he's always
like hey you want to watch the Super
Bowl shows she did over and over he's
got a saved on his iPhone it's a it's
weird but it is what it is
um but he gets to pick the show uh the
song that wrapped up today's show and of
course he picked his favorite the one
he's always singing around the office
um you just be in the bathroom coming
out of one of the Stalls top of his
lungs t-o-l is
the great Katy Perry's Firework and it
goes like this
maybe the greatest opening line of a
song ever
do you ever feel like a plastic bag
Catherine Perry genius genius opening
line do you ever feel like a plastic bag
drifting through the wind wanting to
start a start again do you ever feel
feel so paper thin like a house of cards
one blow from caving in
do you ever feel already buried deep six
feet under screens but no one seems to
hear a thing
do you know that there's still a chance
for you Nathan because there's a spark
in you
you just gotta ignite the light and let
it shine just you gotta own the night
like the Fourth of July and this is when
you're washing your hands in the
bathroom and you just start to turn
behind you and belting out of the Stalls
is this cause baby you're a firework
come on show them what you're worth make
them go
as you shoot across the sky
baby you're a firework come on let your
colors burst make them go ah
you're gonna leave them in awe
and that's when the toilet flushes and
it's super weird but baby you're a
firework hey happy New Year stay in
school don't do drugs we'll see you soon